Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I am your host, David Flanagan, although you
may know me from across the Internet as
Rawkode and, of course, this channel.
It's been a while since we're streamed, you
know, a bit of an update. My office
burnt down in April, and I've had to
rebuild from scratch. So apologies for the lack
of amazing, hopefully amazing cloud native and
development
kind of content. And I'm really excited today
because
this is a tool that I have been
using for a little while now, and I've
started to go kind of all in within
my model repository
and using this to build out development environments
that are just a joy to work with.
And today, we are taking a look at
Devenv,
which is a Next based build tool that
provides a great development experience.
It's reproducible.
It's fast. And as I said, a pleasure
to work with. And to guide us on
our journey of understanding
Next and Devenv and all of the amazing
things we can do for that, I am
joined today by the Kashyx founder and maintainer
of the Devenv project,
Khozar.
Hey, man. How's it going? Hey. Hey. Thank
you so much for inviting me. I'm happy
to be here and to share
the journey
of what we've learned with Nicks.
No. I mean, thank you so much for
for joining me. I'm generally super
pumped, excited, although this is my excited face
in Scotland. But I'm super
excited to be diving into this today and
sharing it with the audience because I have
found that my life from a development environment
standpoint has just been lot simpler since adopting
this tool, and I wanna share that with
the audience as well as get history, context,
flavor, everything else that you can share about
your journey along the way.
So That that being said,
I'm gonna throw you under the bus and
say, why don't you just tell us a
little bit about you, what you've been up
to, and, you know, give us all the
details.
Alright.
Thank you so much. Yeah. So
let's see how long of an intro we
can do. So I've been
I think I've been part of the next
community for quite a while. It's been about
ten years now.
And before, I was doing just consulting and
a lot of Python and and stuff
and a lot of the frustration with packaging
let me and and I was a Gentry
user before.
Like, a lot of the frustration with you
know, all around has let me into Next
very early on.
And I've I've kind of never looked back,
and and, you know, the early days were
the early days, so there was a lot
to do.
But we've come really far in the in
the last ten years.
And then about, like,
I think, six years ago, I was
really happy and and really,
you know, delighted to work with.
That was my kind of first time consulting
gig where we were, like,
essentially using Hydra
to create these, like, huge matrix matrices of
different, like, kernels, different versions of software, and,
like,
running benchmarks with on,
networking cards and drivers, like, specialized built for
them.
And then creating these, like, graphs of, like
you know, if you change the kernel version,
if you change the different software versions, like,
what how does that impact performance and stuff?
And it's just really nice because you can
kind of map through all the kernels, map
through all the different software versions, and kind
of generate derivations,
which are, like, the the builds of of
executing that benchmark.
So that was really nice first
gig. And then I after that, I worked
with IOHK as a DevOps lead,
intro like, introducing NICs into the whole process
there
of, like, building the blockchain, blah blah blah.
And then after that, I created CashX as
I saw that. Like, I wanted to do
a lot of NICs as part of IHK,
but, of course, that was not a priority
there, although we did a lot of great
work there on NICs. So then I started
cache x,
and then it's been about five years now,
I think,
building
first binary cache, then deployments, and and then,
like, a year and a half ago, we
started Devenv.
That's yeah. And a bunch of other stuff
like nix.dev was also our effort, which we
donated in the community
to improve the documentation in the next land
and and things like that.
Anyway, lots of things. I can dive into
any of them if you want. But Yeah.
Awesome.
Yeah. I think we'll start
with the question that I hear most when
I go to conferences and mention next or
anything like this, right, is that
there's a lot of
intimidation.
I think people are are scared about learning
a new language even if the tool itself
is powerful.
And I think there's a common consensus that
it's considered quite academic,
but I think that tide is changing. And
I'm curious on your perspective here. Like,
do you see people
that are coming to speak to you? They're
struggling with next. Do they still think it's
academic? And and do you see this trend
where more people seem to be just embracing
it now,
in the last twelve months? I seem to
think that people are a lot more open
to to using Next and Next tools.
Yeah.
That's a really good question. So I I
think that
it has changed a lot,
mostly because
there is a lot of people from the
industry who are using NAICS and bringing that,
like, mindset into it.
So I I don't see
like, the academic side, I don't see it
mentioned almost at all anymore. I think a
lot of that has
is due to Rawk Arbus who led, like,
the redesign of nixos.org
about a few years ago, maybe three years
ago.
And, like, the original website was very academic.
Like, you could really see, you know, it's
like talks about purely functional and all these
words that, like, nobody cares
at the end of the day, right, what
they wanna do with nix.
So that has changed a lot into what
the industry is used to, which is, like,
you know, showing off the features and the
benefits of of using the Nikes and things
like that. So I think the redesign of
the website was a huge
move. And then also, like, just people
all around who are, like like, you know,
bringing that
developer experience mindset to makes and and trying
to make it better and and more stable
and things like that. I think it's like
no single thing, but it all kind of,
you know, trickles up
or trickles down to
to what we have right now.
Yeah. Definitely. I mean, I think the academic
side for me is whenever I hear someone
say hermetic or adampotent, I'm like, okay. Here
we are again. It's something hard, but, you
know, these things, they they mean something different
in each context. And I think the next
context is something that is, like, containers now.
Right? We take these for granted. And I
think next is maybe the next the next
kind of adoption point that we're gonna see
in this space. But let's break down next.
Right? Because we've said a few things. Now
you said next to us. There's next. These
are actually many projects. Right? There's next to
language. There's next to package manager. There's next
to us, the operating system.
I I don't even know if I've missed
anything there, to be honest, but you don't
need to buy into all of this. You
can pick and choose the parts you want.
Right?
Yeah. So I think the most confusing part
is that, like,
we don't really have a good name for
the project. There was a times where we
called it the.
There was sometimes where we called it. So
it's been a lot of discussions. I've been
big proponent even when I was still in
the foundation to
to to pick a name that, like, is
for the project itself that is completely distinguished.
But, yeah, NICS is, like, kind of, like,
the language, then it's, like, the package manager,
and then kind of, like, the whole facade
of of tooling. Right? And then, like, Nick
so has built on top of that and
provides his own interface and, for example, Devenv
as well.
So it's quite a quite a few layers,
and I think that's the and
what used to be really hard as well
that NICS was really hard to Google because
it was, like, Unix and and things like
that were, like, popping up now that NICS
is so popular.
I think Google is doing a great job
of prioritizing us,
but that's likely solved.
But, yeah, that all creates this confusion. But,
like, the the essence is you you you
wanna use NICs. That's kinda like the core.
NICs is like the distribution, I would say,
where you get, like, the the the actual
common line.
And then you can, like, slowly progress
into, like, do you wanna have developer environments?
Do you wanna have deployments?
So, like, there is a lot of different
projects. There's, like, Nick's Darwin, which manages, like,
your Mac OS kind of configuration,
home manager, and and then there's a lot
of projects. But, like, the essence is
kind of, like, the common line tool and
then the language
itself.
Okay. So let's lean into the dev end
aspect of this then. This is the project
that we wanna show people today.
In order for someone to get started and,
you know,
recreate some of the things we're going to
do today, which parts of Dext are they
buying into. Right? It's is it the Next
language? Is it Next packages? Do they need
NextOS? Like,
how does Devenv and Next correlate?
Yeah. So
one of the
I don't know. I this is a bit
of a
thing that I like to say that NICS
is kind of like the JavaScript of DevOps.
Right? Because the language is like
you know, it's it's an old language by
now, and it's it's
there's a lot that could be fixed or
changed initially.
So we're kind of stuck with what it
is
because we don't wanna break backwards compatibility.
So
especially,
like, conversions between different types and things like
that are are quite
tricky for beginners, I would say.
So one of the insights that I had
was like, okay. We we don't wanna, like,
really use all the features of the language.
What we wanna expose to the users is,
like, very simple API, which is essentially, like,
the attributes that you kind of toggle to
to some values.
So,
like, previously, I think if you use, like,
Nick Shell and things like that, it's great.
But, like, you needed to know quite a
bit of the language to kind of get
things, like, wired up.
So Devenv kind of, like, hides all that
complexity away and kind of exposes this SIP.
Like, I like to describe it as, like,
a simple JSON language
with, like, functions. Right? Because if you don't
really dive into the dark corners, that's that's
what you you know, we need a book,
like, makes the good parts. Right? I think
it's exactly the same as the JavaScript.
So, like, that was the insight. Right? We
wanna really dumb down the use of the
language and things that people
need to do to in order to use
to start with Next. Yeah. Because one of
the the the main, like, complaints that you
hear from people about Nicks is that, oh,
it's you know, like, hard things are easy,
but easy things are hard. And I think
that this this part where easy things are
hard is mostly the developer experience that is
just been quite
a quite a hard thing. So that's what
we've been, like, really focusing on with Devenv
and trying to, like, start from, like, pleasurable
experience and then make it functional later. So
it's very controversial take on software.
But,
yeah, that's the the approach we took.
Awesome. Well, I'm excited to dive into this.
I think we should probably share my screen
and dive into Devenv, show people how to
get started, and explore some of those,
you know, quirks of the language as we
progress.
Let's try it out. Yeah.
Fingers crossed. So for anyone watching that does
want to get started here, you can just
go to devenv.sh,
where everything that you need is there, including
some samples of the language, the documentation,
and
again, the starter guide, which we're gonna kick
the tires on.
So,
normally, I would do the install, but I
actually already have
I mean, I'm running Nexus today just for
this session, so that's kinda cheating. Right? But
most people would have to have Next available
on their system.
As we've kinda covered, you know, it's available
on Linux, Mac OS.
So quite
easy ish to get started,
we're not gonna cover this. Now
this is where I got tripped up when
I first explored Devenv. So I'm hoping you
can get a guide us on this part.
Right? Is that to use Devenv, we actually
have multiple options once Next is available on
our system.
We can install the package into our environment
using Next Shell, NextM, something like this.
There's profiles and flakes,
which are a completely different approach to doing
it. Right? We can use the profile, but
we could also use a flake.next. I'm still
not entirely sure. Like, my next knowledge is
very
beginner. Right? I know enough to be dangerous
and get a development environment up and running,
but I don't really understand all of the
the rest of the ecosystem at this point
in time. So what I'm curious about, and
I'm gonna try and give you a specific
question now instead of fluffing and waving my
hands in the air. Right? But you know
Next. You know Devenv. You built this tool.
When you are starting a new project,
do you go straight for a flake dot
Next? Do you use a Devenv CLI tool?
Do you do something else? Like, what do
you do, and what would you encourage other
people to do?
Yeah. I I was
I used to be, you know, a huge
huge fan of and I still am a
huge fan of of flakes because I think
that
the flakes solve a lot of the issues
with, like,
handling dependencies and things like that. So that's
where I would start, like, before I did
Devenv.
And then as I started to work on
Devenv, I started to use it more and
more because
I kind of, you know, follow the Pareto
rule of eighty, twenty percent, and I think
80% of the time,
you want just the developer environment for your
project. That's, like, most of what you need,
I I think, when you are developing things.
And
because we've we've put so much work into
Devenv, I think that it's it's a much
simpler option.
So I now it's just
I I would always go for Devenv. The
only time where I would use Steelflakes is
when
you really need to, like, distribute software.
Like, that's that's the part that Devenv doesn't
do,
at least at the moment.
And and but, yeah, that's that's a different
end topic. Like, what are the differences between
Flakes and Devenv.
But we yeah. I would use Devenv now
for I mean, I'm obviously biased toward Devenv
because I I created it. Like so if
I say that, it doesn't mean that much.
But it is like
you know, I I still when I open
a project, I decide if I wanna use
flakes or not. So it's yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. I I was just curious, you
know, what you would reach for. And I
think for the audience as well that aren't
gonna have as much experience with you and
next. It's definitely the easiest way for them
to get started as well. So let's go
ahead and just make sure I have
in my environment.
Don't know why that Yeah. It needs this.
Yeah.
Now if you have flakes,
this might complain,
but let's see. This is, like, gonna show
the
the experience.
Oh, you're using the z Zelly Jane or
whatever is
Yeah.
It's such a good multiplexer.
It's fantastic.
Nice. I should try.
So let's see if that will work.
Ta da.
Awesome.
So install Devenv CLI, and then in order
to create a new repository or add a
Devenv to an existing project, I would guess,
we could run Devenv
in it.
So
I was gonna do this. Like, right right
now, we're in an empty directory that has
nothing in it. I mean, we could certainly
do that and add some components and stuff,
but maybe it would make more sense to
add this to an existing
project. I don't know. What do you think?
Yeah. I think,
usually, you wanna
you kind of
have an idea of what developer environment you
want to build
for, you know, what's what source you have
and and and, you know, what you you
wanna, like
I don't know. Let's say you have a
Rust project. Right? So it's Let's do it
let's do it this way. I mean, I'm
not gonna put words in my audience's mouth.
Right? But they're typically cloud native senior developers
who are programming in Rust or Go. So
I think if we can try and run
through two examples,
the very simple Go program and the Rust
program, I think that's gonna be of most
value to the people that watch this video.
Maybe I'm wrong, but I think that is
our best bet for today. So
let's start with Rust first because it's my
go to language these days, and I'm gonna
run Devenv in it, and then we'll take
it from there.
Now here's a a question. What
language is Devenv
written in?
Yes. It's it's a good so first, when
we create like, when I created
Devenv, it was just, a glorified Bash script
because we were just trying to
just, like, yeah, get the interface right and
all that.
Then I rewrote it to Python because I
thought, okay. That would kind of, like, attract
more people to contribute. You know, it's it's
a much better language to to kind of,
like, write common line interfaces.
But then I rewrote it to Rust, actually.
So some people were a bit like, woah.
What the hell is going on?
But what happened was I went to, like,
something called
what what was it called,
Tiger Sprint, which was like a next
hackathon of of about 20 people.
And,
like, I was really happy. There was a
friend who said, okay. I can, you know,
I can teach you Rust pair programming.
And I said, yeah. I wanted to learn
Rust. So in a week, we rewrote Devenv
in in Rust from Python.
And I was like, okay. If if that's
done in a week, then I'm happy.
And and so now it's in Rust, which
is which is actually not, like, completely arbitrary
or just because Rust is cool. But it's
also because there is a lot of tooling
being written in Rust, so I think it's
nice that the community is approaching to to
Rust or, you know, any language, really. But
it is Rust, and and I think Rust
is a great language.
So that's one thing. The other one, there
is Twigs, which is like a rewrite of
of NICs in Rust,
Twigs.dev.
And I'm I'm
kind of really excited about that. I I
don't know how well it will go, but
I think that it's it's super cool that
well, first of all, we have an alternative
implementation of NICs. And second of all,
I think it's,
you know, it's it's done with the right
foundations and things like that. So, potentially, we
could integrate Wix at some point into Devenv,
but that's, like, up in the air.
Excellent. Yeah.
Well, we have
our first question, which is more related to
the pronunciation of what I said, but Hain
is saying that it rhymes with prestige.
So I guess that's zelisch? Zelisch. Zelleys?
I guess. Yeah.
Alright.
Yeah. Feel free to use the comment box,
people. If you have any questions or you
want Domin to answer anything, feel free just
to drop it, and then we'll get to
it as soon as possible.
But for the moment, we have ran Devenv
in it,
and we have a lock fail, a next
fail, and a YAML fail. I'm gonna pop
this open in Versus Code.
All the random pop ups that I get.
Oh, no. We are okay. These are just
hidden stuff. Right? So Mhmm. What do you
wanna look at first? YAML, Next?
I usually always open Next first.
And yeah.
Alright.
So what we have is some Next code
that defines
environment variables, packages,
scripts,
and some enter stuff. Do you wanna just
kinda give us the the quick walk through
of this this this kind of scaffolding?
Yeah. So, like,
essentially, we have a bunch of called attribute
sets, what we call in eggs, but they're
kind of nested. So, for example, the first
example is env,
which is
where you can define environment variables.
So
that's,
like, very commonly used
in the in the environments,
like, either, you know, by
there's also dot env inter dot env integration.
So that's the most commonly used thing that,
you know, you wanna store secrets and things
like that, which will then populate the env
attribute
for you from from that dot env file.
So that's,
like, kind of the one of the basic
things, and the other one is the packages,
so where you can define
whatever packages you want to have available in
your developer environment.
And this all piggybacks on next packages. So
whatever is available there
is available also here.
There's, like, Devenv search command, which kind of
helps you to to search through the options
and through the packages at the same time.
So,
like, if you wanna I don't know. If
you type in, like, Postgres, you will see
options from Devenv that you can set for
Postgres well and and also the packages or
and extensions and things like that that you
can set.
And then there is, like, a bunch of
other things like
scripts,
which essentially allows you to define different kind
of scripts.
You this is, like, by default batch, but
now we've just recently added support that you
can, like, write Python scripts or Rust scripts
or whatever and
just kind of inline them or even import
them from another file or whatever.
So that's I think that's kind of nice.
So those are then available inside the the
the environment.
Then enter shell and enter test are kind
of like two
like, kind of usually, next, they would be
typically called hooks.
So enter shell executes this bash code when
you enter the environment,
and enter test
executes when you write Devenv test, which is
like this
glorified way of,
okay. Set me up the environment, set up
the processes, which I'm gonna mention a bit
later,
and everything, and then run this test. Right?
So it's kinda like a functional testing or
whatever you wanna call it,
which is, I think, pretty cool
feature that we added also quite recently.
So
maybe maybe this needs a bit of a
different order now that I'm talking about it.
But at the bottom, you can see there's,
like, languages that you can set,
which is
makes makes as a default
as an example,
but that we have about, I think, 51
or 52 languages right now, and it's super
easy to add Numos.
And then the the most exciting part, least
for me, is, like, processes and services. So
processes is just the way it is it's
like a foreman
profile kind of format where you just define,
you know, whatever
whatever command you wanna run inside your environment
that is, a long running process.
And then the services are, like, basically, obstruction
on top of that. So, like like, Postgres,
you know, you it will run a Postgres
process for you, but expose a bunch of
a bunch of settings for you. So you
can set, like, the initial database or
where do you want Postgres to listen on
the auth and things like that. Yep. And
and I think there's also, like, about 30
of them, like, you know, Redis,
different, like, mail,
like, testing services and and and a lot
of really commonly used,
yeah, develop developer
processes
that you wanna have available
that are common,
like, besides your application server, for example. So
you would define, like, application server stuff as
a process because it's, like, your thing, And
then services are the the things that you
usually kind of, like, piggyback on.
And then I think, yeah, there's also pre
commit hooks. I'm a huge fan of pre
commit hooks. I think that they're,
like, hated mostly because, actually,
it's super hard to set them up.
So, like, makes that makes that part super
easy.
Another one is that I think that people
don't use them correctly. Like, you you wanna
have pre commit hooks locally that just run
on the files that you modified, and that
should be, like, super quick. So when you
commit something, it shouldn't take more than a
second for them to run.
So they kind of enforce,
like, formatting and and and linting and things
like that.
But then the CI,
here by default, if you enable any pre
commit hook, will already automatically run as part
of the Devenv test.
So that is, like, kind of, like, the
CI level where you want to enforce that
everything is really, like, across the whole code
base, like,
formatted. And if it's not, then that that
should kinda fail on your CI.
So I I think that's I don't know.
I I really like them, and there's a
lot of people using those. So I'm I'm
really happy that
to see that kind of adoption.
Nice.
Alright. There's a few things there I wanna
touch on. The first one, I'll do pre
commit hooks first just because that was the
last thing you mentioned. I love the idea
of Devenv automating that for me. The challenge
I've always had is that every project that
I do is in a mono repository,
and the commit hooks are kinda globally scoped
to that point. So I've never actually been
able to get them work in a way
that as a jumper on service use. It
only loads the hooks that I need for
that service.
So, yeah, I like the idea. I just
haven't seen an execution that works for me
personally yet. But then a lot of people
aren't building in mono repositories for the moment.
So maybe it's an an easy one for
people that are watching.
The other thing
sorry. Do you have something to say there
before I just waffle on for a bit
longer? No. I'm I'm just curious about the
use case. So, like, it's
you you
would like, so monorepo
okay. That means you have, like, kind of
sub sub projects and you you would want,
like, pre commit hooks defined per that third
project. Right? Kind of like
Yeah. I would need to take an EMVRC
that unloaded the hooks as I jumped around
and then only run them against that directory,
which is probably quite tedious and cumbersome. But
yeah.
That there's just a way that everything I
have is in one repository. My Rawkode Academy
repository is all in there. Dozens dozens of
services.
That's interesting. I I
yeah. We need to think about it. But
Look. I'll open an issue, and we can
we could have a chat. Yeah. That's that's
great. That's perfect.
The the thing that drove me to Devenv
is something that you also kind of, you
know, I think you focused on and you're
gonna run through this file, which is processes
and services.
Now the reason that that is what brought
me over is that this is something
I've done with containers since
2015.
Right? So nearly ten years now. And I've
written thousands.
I've got tens of thousands of Docker Compose
files in my life.
And they've worked. Right? But there's no composition.
I can't really define what Kafka or what
Redis, what MongoDB are, and then reuse them
and consume them. And there are tools that
that that try to solve this, but nothing's
ever really worked. And I always found that
I was rebuilding and reimplementing the same health
checks over and over again and copying and
pasting it from project to project.
When I seen Devenv does this through, you
know, services dot, you know, Kafka enable, etcetera,
I was like, woah. That that is really
cool. This is what we need.
But more importantly than that is that container
based workflows are really difficult for people that
aren't running on Linux because containers aren't native.
On Windows and on Mac, there's virtual machines,
and they've never really solved that fail syncing
thing for hot reload to actually work effectively.
And I think that this is why Next
is probably gonna be gaining a lot more
momentum, at least in the circles of in
the people that I speak to over the
last year, is that they need something that
truly is cross platform that runs on
Windows or Mac and Linux. And I don't
know if Next does run on on Windows,
but outside of WSL. Right? But it there
it certainly runs on Mac and it certainly
runs on Linux And giving people an a
development environment that is actually native to the
host, I think is really important. And the
fact that Devenv brings these services and processes
across does make a lot of things easier.
That that that is the sole thing that
won me over. And I think we definitely
need to show off some of the amazing
things you can do with services and processes
as part of our demo team. But I
know I just get a waffle there, but
I think it's so important. I think it
just makes life so much easier for so
many people or can make life so much
easier for so many people.
Oh, yeah. For sure. So, like,
what what's really interesting is that, like, one
of the major users of Devenv right now
from, like, my,
like,
how to say, nonstatistical
assessment
is that there's a lot of PHP users,
actually.
And that is because
they
they have a lot of knobs to churn.
For example, debug. Like, they they turn some
PHP stuff with debug on and sometimes not.
And a lot of these
container based Docker
style
builds, they just don't compose. Right? So as
soon as they saw the dev can can
allow them to, like, quickly switch versions, enable
debug for different processes and things like that,
they were like, okay. That was immediate sell.
And then on top of the fact that
Docker is super slow on Mac OS, so
a lot of developers,
like,
needs like, it's a huge penalty for them,
that fact that it runs natively. Yep. Those
two things just was an instant sell,
and and there's, like, really a lot of
PHP developers.
Yeah. And it's not just it's any it's
not just PHP. It's any interpreted language. We're
talking about Python, Ruby, PHP. You know. These
large projects have tens of thousands of files,
and syncing them to a VM is never
gonna really ever be fast. I know they're
trying, but it's been ten years and it's
not been a solved problem yet. So,
yeah, all of these people have a lot
of benefits from just running that Devenv and
then getting started with a local environment.
Now let's get back to actually making this
do something.
Let's try. Yeah. So we said this is
gonna be a Rust project.
I'm assuming
well, I do have cargo.
I can't remove cargo. Right? That's just something
I've got.
That was it rebuilding my system. And let's
just get a local cargo.
I don't even know how I'm gonna be
able to kinda show that. Right? Because this
is my next profile cargo. Mhmm. So let's
just change in fact, let's leave next because
I'm curious about what we can what that
we'll show people.
Let's just do Rust enable.
Mhmm.
And if I just hit return,
this is automatically going to reload and augment
my environment because
we have the ENVRC here, which tells it
to use Devenv as part of our process.
Right? Mhmm. Just by me hitting return, running
any command, c d ing out and into
this directory,
we can now see that it is fetching
next stuff and eventually rust stuff to give
us a the tools that we need to
successfully run and instantiate this project.
Now while that runs, maybe you could give
us a little bit of information on,
you know, when I enable next, enable Rust,
what is Devenv?
What is it establishing? What is it doing
for me?
Yeah. So,
like, a a lot of times when you
develop for a specific language, you kind of
need to look up,
you know, what compiler do I need, what,
like like, debugger do I need, maybe, you
know, some profiling tools, language server support, things
like that. So Devenv has this philosophy of
kind of enabling all of that by default.
So it's, like, not full batteries in terms
of, like, everything everything, but it tries to
to kind of balance that out and says
that, like, anything that you would potentially,
80% of the time use, we kind of
enable it.
And then you have knobs to potentially disable
that
if you need to. But, like, I think
yeah. This is, a design choice. Right? Either
you go super minimal and then you have
to enable each thing. But I think, like,
downloading those few megabytes of each tool is,
like, quite
not a big price to pay. I mean,
at least us, we're privileged to live in
fiber optics
or or good Internet, but, hopefully, everyone
will be at that you know, is
going towards that in the world.
So I think that that's kinda like the
design philosophy.
And and we are, like, trying to for
example, right now, Krishna is working on adding
language support. So, like, you will be able
to get language
sorry, language server support. So you will get
for each language
already that preconfigured and, you know, your editor
just picks it up and things like that.
So,
yeah, that's, like, the simple then
in for example, in Rust case,
you have a bunch of options. You can
pick, you know, the tar you can set
the targets. You'd be like I don't know.
You wanna target WASM. We we do that.
You wanna,
like, pick a different channel. Let's say you
want Nike Rust. Right? We we have support
for that.
So you can kind of, like, tweak your
way into
how you want that to be from our
defaults that we provide.
Yeah. So let's dive into that a little
bit. No. I don't have fiber at my
new office yet. I am waiting very patiently.
Have to make my It's quite
a lot. But if we go to this
languages page,
for a start, it just lists everything.
But if we wanna find the options for
languages, this is gonna take us to here.
Mhmm.
So if people do want to tweak and
configure what they get,
we can scroll down. Let's find the Rust
example.
Quite a lot of PHP stuff there, actually.
Maybe we should've done that.
But let's find Rust.
So we can have enable. We can change
the channel as you said.
We can add components. So by default, we're
actually getting the compiler. We're getting cargo, clippy,
Rust format, and Rust analyzer, which is fantastic.
And then there's Rust flags, molds, targets, etcetera.
So, yeah, everything that people need to be
able to tweak and configure the way this
this language support works,
you could just come to this page
and even just go through to the source
if you wanna take a look at the
next that makes this happen. And this is
one of the things that I thought was
amazing when I stumbled across Devenv and started
using it. Is that, like, 90% of it
is just next code too. Right? Like, if
we go to the the homepage, it's like,
yeah, you got your 20% Rust, but most
of this is just next code that facilitates
that. I I don't know if it's templating
or spec or whatever,
but yeah. So this is a good way
for people to get familiar with Next by
taking a look at the components, languages, processes,
and services that you provide
I support.
Yeah. That's the beauty of next. It it
really does. So, like, Devenv, the way I
say it is, like, we took our expertise
of how you should set up things and
we kind of, like, obstructed that away. Right?
Which is the main
pain point of many people who came to
Nick's. Was like, oh my god. It's it's
difficult to to pull everything together, and you
need to be a Nick's expert.
And it's like, no. It doesn't have to
be that way. Right? It's just about
a pattern called convention over configuration,
which is, like, you know, by default, you
get a really good set of things, and
then you kind of configure
your way into your desired path, right, rather
than you get a blank slate
and then, you know, you need to build
everything yourself.
So, like, in the past, you know, the
way I see it, there was a lot
of early adopters of NICs, like me, who
were super enthusiastic to hack their way through.
But now people just they don't wanna learn
NICs. Right? What they want is, like, a
developer environment and do their work. So this
is where
this is kind of, like, the gap that
I see we're trying to fill in here.
Nice.
Alright. Well, my Internet caught up. And if
I run which cargo again,
we now have a next store path for
the Devenv version of this.
And I just wanna kinda
highlight this. If if I jump out
from Which Cargo, we go back to the
original.
And if I jump back in,
we go back to the store. So I
love this
loading, unloading as I move around, and I'm
only getting the tools for this project that
I need.
Sweet. So let's get some Rust code.
Cargo in it.
And
let's see.
We have hello world.
Now
we could just use Cargo. Right? We could
do our build. We could run the project,
but we wanna lean into more Devenv features.
So, again, in your experience and and what
you do, what what's your next steps? How
are we looking at and bringing in more
of Devenv's convenience to people as they adopt
in their project?
Yeah. So I think it would be two
parts. One is, like, you would configure Rust.
Let's say you want to use mightly
channel because, you know, you're using some some
features from from there. So you would first,
like, explore what what options we support for
for us or, you know, even add like,
it's quite easy to add, like, new new
configurations
options.
Well, that's a bit advanced, so that's maybe
later on. But the the second part would
be to define the processes. You know? Like,
usually
like, a simple way to is just a
simple watch. You know? Watch this directory for
changes. Like, you can add, like there's, like,
a ton of watcher programs.
And then when something changes, execute something. Right?
That's, a very simple process that
Yeah.
I don't know. For example, you have Tailwind
and you want compile CSS. Right? So every
time that Tailwind
file changes, you compile the CSS.
Or, like, you would run a cargo watch,
for example, right, in as a process
as a development process.
That those would be the first two steps,
I think. And then the the third one
would be the pre commit hooks, in my
opinion, is to to, like, enable clippy,
enable,
you know, format Rust format or and things
like that.
Okay. Let's try and go through each of
those one at a time. So
right now,
let's try and set up the cargo watch.
So every time I change my main to
r s, it's gonna recompile our project for
us. I think that would be a good
step. So is this something we're gonna add
to to enter shell? Do we do a
different way? How would you set that up?
The cargo watch, I would just add it
to at the top when you have processes.
So maybe
sorry. At the bottom. Oh, yes. Left,
right.
Yeah. So I don't know. Here, you just
pick a name you want, like cargo watch
and here.
And I I don't think cargo ships the
watch by default, does it? Oh, it doesn't?
Okay. Oh, it
yeah. So we have to add that as
a package, don't we?
Uh-huh.
Okay.
That's a I have no idea how that's
done. I guess packages dot cargo minus watch
would be my
Yeah.
Let's see.
I think you just
yeah. There is legacy packages. Yeah. I think
you just
Is it gonna be, like, a cargo Cargo
minus watch. Packages?
It should No. I think just cargo minus
watch should be. Okay. I don't know if
that works well together, but probably it does.
Let's try.
I have to admit that I I don't
I don't use because I have language server
support in my editor, so I I usually
don't use it.
Alright. So what we've done here,
added the package that we need,
created a process. Now processes are only executed
when we spin
up the development environment. Is that correct? Mhmm.
Yeah. This is like the run processes command
kind of work,
which is heavily inspired by the the proc
file.
Alright.
So what you see here is is some
a project called, process compose,
which I found is
one of the best tools for this, like,
kind of development environments
processes
preview. So at the top, you just see
a list of processes that you can click.
I mean, now we have only one, so
there's not much to to go. But then
as you kinda switch up and down or
whatever or
with with the mouse, then you at the
bottom, the locks kind of change so you
can kind of see locks for each process.
And you can, like, control r to restart
it and things like that. So it's it's
really convenient.
Takes a bit of learning as any tool,
but I found it's the best one. You
can also turn on different ones like Overmind,
which I think is like a TMax
based
or Honcho, which is like a implementation
of Foreman.
And, potentially,
any can be implemented as a way to
to run this.
Nice.
But, yeah, this is a good default one.
Make a change.
Say hello world with two exclamation marks,
and there we go. We get our
thing running in the background. So that's pretty
neat. Nice easy way to get started adding
a custom process.
But it's not just custom processes. Right? If
we come back to our devhunt.next,
we have these
kind of not managed, but provided
services.
Exactly. Yeah. So So here you see the
the full list of what's currently supported.
Yeah. I mean, the fact that temporal is
here, I have struggled many times to set
up temporal development environments. And for Devenv, it's
a one lane flag, which is great. So
Yeah. So it's you know, each of this
is a lot of time spared
for yeah. And even, like, you know, I
I like that like, you know, if you
use Docker, you always have this
paradox of choice. Right? You wanna run Postgres
or, you know, whatever, and then you go
to Docker Hub, and now you need to
pick which one you want to run.
I mean, this is getting better by by
creating more official ones, but I I find
that it's nice here. You just have one,
and that's it.
Yeah. But even with the official ones, you
still have to learn what environment variables you
need. You have to work out the liveness
probes and all of that, and
there's none of that that is specifically needed
here. So let's just enable this one.
I'm trying not to pull down too much
with my 50 meg connection at the moment,
but let's try to be
Postgres and Temporal.
And for this, I'm just going to do
quit,
and it's already reevaluating my environment.
And here we go. Alright. It's not too
bad.
Yeah. It shouldn't take too long.
Well, that does that. I guess we could
add a
well, we've got shells and we've got tests.
Right? So Mhmm. And we've this custom script
here. So this would be another cool thing
to show people, I think.
Let's add a script to build our project.
Mhmm. Build.
Exact.
And this could just be cargo build.
And then
and the shell, we can just,
yeah, we can just do something something like
this.
Here, into test, you could run cargo test,
for example. Right? That would be
Yeah. I mean, it should tell us we
have, you know, zero tests, but that's okay.
Yeah. I mean yeah.
And let's just add an emoji because everything
is better with an emoji. Right? So I
actually don't know how to type emojis
on my Linux machine.
On Mac, I use Raycast, but I don't
think I have anything configured for that here.
So we're going old school.
Okay. So let's just reload this one more
time. We have an enter key. This will
set up our new script, our enter shell,
and our enter test, plus we could take
a look at the new services we now
have available. So
let's start with the
scripts.
We added one called build.
This is just a convenience layer, right, to
the point where people could just execute any
of those script names and it runs the
command for them.
Mhmm. As far as
again, I wanna dive into, like, your experience.
Right? This is you've been doing this for
a long time now.
It's very easy for people to reach for,
like, a just file or a make file.
Do you see these scripts as, an alternate
alternative to that? And I mean, that's through
composition. Like, if I run build, can it
do multiple steps? Or should people still reach
for adjust file or make fail? Like, how
do you see that working
now and and the future?
Mhmm.
I I think that the scripts are quite
powerful. So you because in Snakes, you can
substitute a lot of things inside. Right? So
you have a programming language, so you can
kind of reuse snippets and things like that.
So, like, even
even if you would, like, have things that
depend on each other, you you could kind
of abuse them to, like, just,
you know, like, inline the scripts if you
have, like, one thing and then the other
should run. So you could have, like, build
and then tests, and then inside test, it
runs the build. So you can do quite
a lot. But I think once you really
once it really gets complex, then probably you
should reach out for for more framework y
approach.
I don't know. Just file, make file, whatever
is your favorite one.
But I think that you can get quite
far with this one.
So, yeah, here here, you need to do
config dot scripts. So this is like config
is a special thing. It's like, essentially, you're
referencing the
the the environment you're configuring. So, like, this
Devenv
definition is essentially a function where at the
top, if you go to the very top,
it's like a function of of a few
arguments.
And what's it's returning is config, but you
also get this config as an input. So
you can reference things
as you define them. So the the tricky
bit, of course, is you can create infinite
recursion if you would reference the config now
in the build part of the scripts. That
would get into some horrible error messages.
So that's probably the hardest bit of mix
Yeah. If you kind of
get those recursion errors. But, like
like, yeah, if you have to to just
get the intuition about this that you are,
like, referencing
the what you're returning.
But it's really neat, right, that you can
do this.
Yeah. I mean, would you welcome a pull
request that loop like
dependencies?
Like, I know this is not doesn't really
make sense, but, I mean, something like that
could probably be quite a good approach as
well.
Yeah. Exactly. Yeah. I I I like that
because this is exactly the,
like, the mindset behind Devenv is not to
use these advanced next features, but but, like,
dump them down exactly in what you're saying.
So that's that's a good one. Yeah. I
think I mean, I yeah. I could write
a just file, and I can just execute
them within file. That's that's a perfectly good
way to do it. And I think a
lot of people would probably do that. But
as I lean more into Devenv, I wanna
do more stuff that
that way. So yeah. There's something just for
me to think about in the future. Anyway,
let's pop back over here. So we added
our scripts.
I'm gonna run that publish one just because
I I didn't know you could do that
interpolation within the the script itself. That's pretty
neat. So if I do publish, yeah, we're
build in the publishing. Awesome.
We also did Shell test and services.
So we've already seen Devenvap,
so let's run it again. And we should
see that we now have a process composed
with multiple processes running.
And we can show people that switching between
the processes to see the logs and see
what's happening. So there's our cargo check.
Our Postgres is currently spinning up. It's not
quite ready yet. Our temporal is already
on the way and quite happy. I love
that. It's so powerful.
And now Postgres is ready as well. So
It's pretty crazy how simple it is. Right?
I don't know. It makes me smile each
time.
Yeah. Three lines of code. Like,
unbelievable. I mean, think of how much that
would take in a Docker compose just because
YAML doesn't have that level of composition
and
remote packages and all this other wonderful
feature. I absolutely love that. Cool.
If that doesn't win people over, nothing will.
So
Exactly. You drop it off now, you know.
My fault. Alright. Let's quit this.
So
there we go. And the last thing that
we've shown so far is the Devenv
shell.
Am I already in a shell?
Yeah. So because you're using the dir enf,
which is like this tool that you're using
that when you just enter it, kind of,
behind the scenes, enables the shell.
Yeah. So if we just pop out and
then pop back into Rust and what we're
looking for is that we should see this
run entering shell and
get version, which
we have here.
That's a neat feature.
And the last one was our dev and
test.
Yeah. So I think this is another thing
that is
not well known and and kind of new,
but I found this I find this really,
like,
really nice feature.
I
don't know what's happened now.
But,
yeah, the the fact that you can run
things with the whole environment enabled locally, I
think that's quite unique.
Yeah. So our test ran and they're successful.
It's just all the the process noise in
the background. Oh, yeah. This is, like, shutting
down,
like,
errors.
So yeah. I wonder if you can hide
those.
Maybe maybe we need to improve the the
output
there a bit
because it's a bit in because, like, what
we're doing is, like, we are running the
processes,
piping that to a standard output, and then
also whatever the test is running. So that
can be a bit confusing.
Yeah. There's definitely a flag that hey. The
surface logs would be
Yeah. But
regardless, that is some serious amount of
power, I guess. Right? And convenience. Mhmm. But
convenience more than power. Think that's the word
I'm looking for. And again, we're at 54
lanes. Most of that was provided to scaffolding
for us, and we've had to change
so very little, but and return. Right? We've
put little in and we're getting a whole
bang for our buck back. And I think
that is just the true now it's the
right word power of Devenv. So I think
that's amazing. Such a great product.
Wow.
Now I'll encourage the audience.
Anything you want to see or ask, now
would be a great time to throw that
into the comments. And, Dom, and I'll ask
you, is there anything of Devenv that we
haven't covered that you think would be really
cool to show the audience? I know we
said we're gonna do a cool example. We
we we could do that too, but I
think probably showing off this Rust one demonstrates
everything that we need people to know about
Devenv. Right?
Yeah. I think the the last missing bit
is, like,
people often ask
how do I how do I then deploy?
Right? Because I want to I wanna have
the same environment potentially
also in production.
So Devenv, like,
ships with kind of a a way to
generate a container out of the development environment.
So there is, like, Devenv container
builds, Devenv container copies so you can, like,
copy it to a registry
or even Rawk, which kind of just runs
Docker Docker in the background at the moment,
but that could be improved
much further, I think.
So, like, you can take this environment and
and then, like, ship a container.
And there's also
a flag, like, container
like, config dot container dot is building so
you can kind of conditionalize
things based on
if you're building a container, or are you
are you just,
you know, entering a developer environment?
So for example,
let's say you have, like, a a managed
Postgres. Right? Then you instead of enable
like, services Postgres enable, you would say instead
of true, you would say then config dot
container dot is building
well, exclamation mark. Right? So you want to
negate that.
And then
I think that's pretty neat. Right? So you're
you're Yeah. You're then, like, conditionalizing
how what goes into container and what goes
into your developer environment.
Nice.
And there's so there's, like, a few different
con like, I think there's two containers that
are provided by default, but you can create
your own. One is just a simple shell.
So if you say container
oh, dev dev container
build
shell, that will build only the the shell.
So let's say that's something that you would
ship.
Oh, I don't have Docker.
Oh, you don't yeah. But I I think
if
you just do builds, you don't you shouldn't
need Docker.
Or do you no. You do need Docker.
Yeah.
But yeah.
I think,
yeah, here it's asking you at the bottom
to to
like, it needs a few dependencies. So you
need to, like Ah, right. Okay. Yeah. Like,
enable
so next to container is a really nice
project.
Oh
oh, Nick's packages. I didn't copy it. Yes.
Yeah. There we go. We should probably
have No. That was me. I think that
was that was my terrible copy of the
pasting. So
Yeah.
Yep.
So now you
right. So now it wants you to set
a name. So, like,
unfortunately,
yeah, that's not the best two weeks, but
you can either set the name for the
whole project
or for the container. But
Yeah. Yeah. For example. And
I think it's gonna ask you for one
more yeah. So one more thing. Now you
need to to enable this one.
Yeah. That's something that we need to improve
the UX like you
if you if you need, like, two dependencies,
we should be able to tell you that
in one go. But Yeah. But even at
that, the fact that I am now building
a container
from this is pretty sweet. I thought I
I actually had no idea that was something
I could do. So
Yeah. So, like really leads me into getting
no. It's all great to have a development
environment. Been able to get something into production
is a different story, and I I just
completely missed
this. So that's very, very cool.
Awesome. Yeah. We have an example for fly.io
where
you just, like, configure their registry and, like,
you can then push these things to to
fly.io,
for example. So it's very easy to go
from developer environment
into production then.
Oh, so is that where where does that
live now?
Test container.
So, yeah, that's
that's that's now part of the department.
No. Wait. If you just do build,
that doesn't that doesn't, like, copy anywhere. I
think that's just built it. That's it. Ah,
alright. Alright. Okay. Okay. It's more like if
you wanna have it as part of the
CI or something.
But then if you wanna do something with
it, you need to either copy it or
run it. Those are the two things we
support right now.
So, like Okay. Copy. Let's see what the
help says.
That just puts a name. I'm gonna call
it test.
Yeah. So by default, it's gonna copy to
to your local Docker
if you have one.
Cool. Alright.
Let's let that finish. So I've got a
question from my point of view, but there's
a couple of things on the chat or
at least one thing in the chat we'll
cover as well. So firstly,
just
says heart. So I'm assuming you're enjoying what
you see, which is amazing.
And then is back with
it would be I'll I'll just gonna put
words in your mouth. It would be good
if an s bomb could be created with
the container and bundled together. Is that something
that you just thought about or considered?
Yeah. So
at actually, there's quite a few projects that
do create SBOMs,
and you we have the whole, like, next
store closure as it's called.
So that should be possible to do. I
haven't
I haven't
I didn't dive into this that much to
to be honest because just it hasn't been,
like, the forefront of what our customers are
using asking for.
But, yeah, it would be pretty neat. I
agree.
Like, for me, the SBOMs, it's always like,
then what do I do with that? Right?
I it feels like the ecosystem is really
huge. So I'm I'm not familiar with with
with the ecosystem yet. I I just need
to dive into it is what I'm trying
to say.
Nice.
But, yeah, should be very doable.
Why did It doesn't matter if it doesn't
work. Maybe it's ran ran out of
disk space or something like this. It's a
bit like, the error messages that you get
from the Docker daemon are a bit weird.
It's super
yeah. It just says, like, okay. Closed pipe,
right, which means that it lost connection to
the daemon, then
sometimes you need to then read the Docker
daemon logs.
So I I don't have I'm using Podman.
I don't know if that's been tested. I
I know they're closely compatible, but may not
they may not be byte for byte compatible,
especially doing something like this.
It could just be my
setup, but we'll give that a moment. Yeah.
K. Let's Yeah. So clear the screen. It's
a 10 gigabyte file. So, like, one of
the,
yeah, one of the things that we need
to do still is, like, dive a bit
into the closure size for the containers right
now
because we have this mentality of pulling everything
in for the developer environments,
then that doesn't work really well for production
as in that the image
that you're copying can be quite big.
But you can disable things. Right? So it's
you can get there. Maybe maybe in the
future, we'll introduce something like profiles where you
will say, like, development for profile and you
get, like, the full blown thing and then
production where you get, like, just the basics
or, yeah, minimal or whatever it would should
be called.
Awesome.
Alright. So it seems there's no more audience
questions, which means you're gonna be stuck with
one of my harder questions, unfortunately. That's perfect.
Right. So one of the things again, this
comes back to my mono repository use case.
And I know that Devenv has some layers
of competition. So I'm curious if there's a
challenge that I have right now that could
be solved using Devenv.
Mhmm. Let's assume we have a second Devenv
project which has Mhmm. Proto buff files.
And it has a build step that compiles
those. It has an output directory.
Mhmm. If I want to consume that output
directory from a different Devenv, is that something
I can do now or in the future?
So you would want to reference those prototype
of,
like, output. Right? The
Yeah. Let let's put a really quick example
with that go directory whenever you use. Right?
So if I do dev end in it.
Mhmm.
And let's just open both of these at
the same time.
And I do apologize if this is a
tough question, but I'm just No. No. It's
a great question. I
like that,
you know, real use cases pop up. Yeah.
Alright. So this isn't obviously not a good
thing, but if we pop this open and
just say that my
build command
creates a file. Now it doesn't matter. That
could be protobufs. It could be anything,
but it creates this artifact called a
Mhmm. And the a directory.
So now here, I can see dev in
fact, I can just run my build step
once I reload my environment.
Oh, out there.
But
Oh, yeah. You need to create a.
Yeah.
So now this project has
had some sort of artifact. But it could
be a pro buff compilation.
It could be
binary from a cargo build. It could be
as
typescript code generated from GraphQL schemas,
anything.
But now instead of my Rust project, I
want to consume
this out a file. Is that something that
Devenv can help me with?
Yeah. So
the short answer is no.
But right now, you cannot really do that.
The longer answer is that, like,
one of the
one of the kind of, like, vision
for Devenv is that, like, right now, you
you can just kind of bring in the
tools, like, the the the packages, the tooling,
the the the processes, and things like that.
But, like, the longer term vision is that
you you will be able to upgrade to
your
whole project, right, so that you can say,
okay. I have a Rust project. Now build
it the whole thing with Next, right, which
means that, like,
your project is built and converted into mix
derivations. So it's built, like, with sandboxing on
and everything like that.
And then once you you would be able
to to do those things,
then that the result of that build is
actually your artifact, and that you would be
able to kind of
compose those those things together.
But that's that's of a,
like, longer term because I think right now
we're focusing on
just creating the environments
because I think that's where people should get
started with Mix. And then Mixifying
your project is usually
not a trivial thing, at at least at
the moment with the tooling.
But that is, like, a lot a lot
more work to get there and to help
people with that.
Okay. So the only way to do that
could be for the Go project to be
its own next derivation and then consume it
that way.
Yeah. So that that's like a
future work
for Yeah. I think if Devenv could
abstract that away so that I don't need
to go deeper into next, that would be
phenomenal. But Yeah. That's that's the goal that
you would you would, like,
say, I don't know, languages.go.mixify
or whatever. I don't know how it will
exactly look. And then it will do its
best that you don't have to do much.
But there are cases where you need to
override things
because
Nix cannot, like, infer everything
it needs, but, you know, by itself.
So that's
that's where it gets tricky.
Awesome.
Alright. Well, thank you so much for spending
time with me today.
I always finish with the same question. It's
like, are you happy to share a bit
about the the road map? Right? What is
next for the Devenv project over the next
three, six, or nine months? What are you
just gonna be tackling next to make people's
lives a little bit easier?
Yeah. So
right now, we're we're just going through, like,
issues people report and trying to to not
stabilize it because I think it's pretty stable,
but, like,
to squeeze out all the the bugs, all
the edge cases because it's such a general
tool of setting up all the languages, processes.
There is quite a lot that people do
with it Yeah. Which is really exciting,
but we are trying to to kind of
go through that.
And then the second thing we're we're looking
into is, like,
kind of reimagining
how CI would work with with the with
the Devenv.
And and
because, like,
what I like about Devenv is, like, a
local first tool, and then
I think that's a better default than a
lot of the CIs today is where, like,
you you first use this, like, arbitrary proprietary
stuff, and then locally, you cannot really replicate
that.
So we're, yeah, we're looking into end of
like, experimenting with with that
because I think it would be pretty neat
to have a clean developer environment built from
scratch, and then that is your CI
where and where everything runs.
Yeah. That's pretty much it. Like, Devenv integrates
already with Cacheck, so, like, you get already
a lot of those features out of the
box.
So that's already done.
Yeah. That's about it. We have another project
that I don't want to
to to to mention mostly because I don't
want us others to copy us yet.
Once we release it, others are feel free
to copy. But I I I'm really excited
about that one as well, unfortunately. I know
I'm super vague, but, yeah,
it's gonna come out sooner than later.
Right. Well, people can always watch this space,
and I'll finish with, you know, the Devenv
as an open source project. You can find
that at github.com/casix/devenv.
I'm assuming your new product is gonna be
launching soon. We'll also be available
there so people can check out the organization,
keep an eye on things. And, of course,
we'll be sure to get tweets and things
out once it does launch.
Any last words, Domin?
I don't know. I just wanna thank you
for for this. It was really great. It's
always great to
to see, you know, that you
how you how you would use it and
the trial we we found a few nice
little things that we can improve on the
way, and that's really valuable.
So, yeah, thank you so much for for
this. It was great for me. I hope
that people enjoyed it as well. Yeah. Again,
thank you. It's always makes my day when
I get to sit down and, you know,
show off a product that I generally
love using. And I hope that other people
are watching this and go check it out
too. So thank you again for your time.
Thank you everyone for watching. We'll see you
all again next time. Have a great weekend.
And, yeah, we'll see you soon. Thank you.
Thank you for watching Rawkode Live.